c'est l'un des comédiens français les
plus emblématiques mais il est
aujourd'hui au cœur d'une sombre
histoire Pierre Palmade victime d'un
chantage à la vidéo intime par un escort
boy en septembre dernier Pierre Palmade
décide de passer un moment avec un
escort boy de 28 ans mais quelques jours
plus tard le jeune homme déjà connu des
services de police tente de lui soutirer
plusieurs milliers d'euros en le
menaçant de diffuser une vidéo intime
c'est qu'un petit avant-goût
développement numéro si tu veux discuter
calmement malgré ces menaces le comédien
décide de ne pas céder face à son maître
chanteur alors que se passe-t-il pour
Pierre Palmade Myriam Palomba nous dit
tout ce soir dans TPMP
Myriam Palomba tire comme par hasard
merci d'être là Myriam
qui est un petit peu d'effets
je me suis fait une entorse
[Musique]
[Rires]
quoi
j'ai regardé moi j'ai fait mais non mais
c'est ridicule
je regardais mes mails
j'attendais là
les retraites ça va pas les personnes
suspendues sont toujours suspendus bref
j'étais dégoûtée et Bob badabou me suis
cassé la figure dans les immeubles
c'est la question
allez c'est parti une maison quand même
hein faut bien avoir un grand appart
parfois qu'une petite maison c'est pas
de moi Stéphane Plaza
Palomba apparemment moi je connaissais
ils sont sa famille hein
allez que s'est-il passé pas pour ta
journée
[Rires]
Pierre Palmade a eu une relation avec un
escort-girl escort boy pardon
c'est une prostituée
masculine sauf que voilà donc en fait
ils ont passé la soirée ensemble ils
s'étaient rencontrés sur une application
il y a une application d'escort boy
voilà il s'était rencontré
mais en vrai en vrai c'est pas enfin le
le monsieur c'est pas présenté à Pierre
Perret comme un escort boy bon bref ils
ont une relation intime pendant quelques
heures le monsieur fait une vidéo dans
de Pierre Palmade dans une position pas
forcément très très sympathique pour lui
et quelques jours plus tard il décide de
lui faire du chantage et de le de les
stocker de 4000 euros ce que Pierre
thalmade refuse catégorie
et donc et donc
il est passé
on en avait parlé donc et après c'est la
deuxième
en 2019 il y a une première affaire à
jeune de 19 ans il a été accusé de viol
mais le jeune garçon s'est rétracté a
dit qu'il avait menti d'accord et là et
là donc il a voulu lui piquer 4000 € à
en lisant à chantage à la sextape
d'accord
donc du coup ce qui s'est passé il a
reçu des textos des ils l'ont mis sous
pression pendant plusieurs semaines deux
semaines Pierre Palmade a pas voulu n'a
pas voulu donner l'argent le problème
c'est qu'ils ont aussi contacté son
ex-femme à savoir Véronique Sanson qui
l'a aussi prévenu donc je n'ai besoin de
personne merci j'adore Véronique Sanson
je suis fan de Véronique Sanson
[Rires]
[Musique]
comment je prends sa tête entre maman
une nuit sur son épaule qui était très
jolie avec Marc Lavoine
[Musique]
[Rires]
et du coup il lui demande
et du coup du coup pierre elle prévient
père Palmade là il décide de prévenir
les policiers qui finalement vont finir
par retrouver le monsieur qui s'appelle
pas Haroun comme il lui avait dit mais
il y a Yassine
et en fait ce qu'on comprend quand même
c'est que c'était quand même une une
relation plus ou moins tarifiée alors
officiellement c'était lui avait donné
une centaine d'euros pour pour lui payer
sa chambre d'hôtel et des nouveaux
écouteurs mais bon voilà d'accord et
donc là
la serre est chaude quand même parce que
est-ce que il y a d'autres stars comme
ça qui ont été victimes de chantage
des stars qui sont victimes de chantage
il y en a eu plusieurs mais surtout
pierre palmat à chaque fois ça lui
arrive assez régulièrement ça comme on
disait tout à l'heure ça lui arrivait en
2019 il a déjà été condamné aussi pour
possession de drogue lui-même dit que il
prend énormément de cocaïne et que ça
l'aide à assumer son homosexualité et
avoir des rapports sexuels
comment dire sans être vulgaire
et du coup et du coup bah c'est vrai
qu'il se retrouve souvent dans des
situations
extrêmement compliquées alors oui et
visiblement il y avait trois hommes donc
les scores il y avait trois hommes
pas le soir pas le soir de le chantage
en bois d'organiser voilà celui qui est
l'escort boy celui qui a appelé
Véronique Sanson et un troisième un
troisième homme qui aurait envoyé des
menaces qui étaient en prison lui qui
était en prison donc c'est vraiment une
bande très organisée et les scores boys
étaient connus des services de police
c'est pour ça pourquoi il avait déjà
travaillé avec lui
il avait déjà été condamné pour
extorsion à but de faiblesse et relance
et il n'avait pas respecté un suivi
voilà oui mais vous savez qu'il y a une
vraie tendance en ce moment pour les
personnalités donc justement pour éviter
les chantages au sextape de la part de
soi d'escort femme ou d'escort homme les
footballeurs ils font signer des
contrats avant pour savoir quel style de
relation sexualité ils ont le droit de
pratiquer avec la jeune fille on doit
laisser les téléphones à la caméra même
de surveillance pour savoir à quelle
heure ils arrivent à quelle heure
football
tous les rapports aussi même sexuel
parce que il y a plein de chantages
c'est bon
en fait le problème dans tout ça c'est
les réseaux sociaux s'inquiète plus en
plus de stars qui drague ouvertement un
visage découvert évidemment les
personnes font des screen donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils font appel à des
escortsboys des escort-girls parce que
tout le monde d'envoyer des photos un
peu au lit voilà donc moi je vous le dis
je n'ouvre jamais mesdames
et des culs rien du tout et du coup ça
ne sert à rien voilà regarde pas
aujourd'hui les écrans sont pas assez
[Rires]
la dernière ça ne passera pas voilà mais
du coup
c'est n'importe quoi donc du coup ils
font appel à des escorteboys ou des
escort-girls parce qu'ils disent que
c'est un gage de confiance que la
personne va rien dire et en fait ils
sont quand même victimes de chantage les
personnes balancent quand même donc ils
savent plus quoi faire en fait ils sont
dans une situation compliquée là et
c'est à cause des réseaux sociaux qui
sont piégés non mais c'est vrai non mais
c'est sûr alors
que vous vous avez déjà été sur des
sites de rencontres comme ça ce que
dites la vérité est-ce que vous avez
déjà voilà draguer sur un site de
rencontre et voilà amener des inconnus
chez vous et vous êtes dit mais on n'est
pas bien allez Mathieu
[Applaudissements]
j'adore parce que moi moi j'ai fait ça
et je regardais pas les yeux pas voulu
le regarder je regardais que Daniel il
est évident que sur les sites gay il y a
les sites gays sont un peu plus j'irai
pas plus violent mais sur les sites
hétéros salut comment tu t'appelles nous
c'est plus rapide
tu cherches tu actives passif quelle
heure ton adresse ça ne fera pas ouais
d'accord
même pas besoin d'un chèque barré trois
dernières déclarations d'impôts
il y a pas une caution bancaire
j'annonce quand même que j'ai au moins
et ça me plaque 15 faux comptes donc de
personnes qui les mecs prennent ta photo
pour attirer plutôt flatteur voilà et
après ils arrivent et c'est pas toi bah
souvent ils prennent juste en fait des
photos pour s'en servir pour attirer
d'autres mecs c'est bon voilà et puis
moi surtout en fait moi c'est pas la
police et tout moi ce qui me sauve c'est
que c'est toi
moi le premier je te le dis 2023 moi
c'est pas à la police tout ça le premier
qui m'emmerde que sereine me faire
chanter et j'ai rien à cacher sur mon
homosexualité je lui envoie lui et c'est
et c'est dogs
je t'envoie toi et tes bras armés et il
y a pas de police il y a pas de tout ça
si on fait des choses illégales je fais
des choses illégales j'envoie tout ça
c'est quelqu'un m'a menacé de quoi 2000
balles ou quoi le premier truc que je
fais c'est je t'appelle ça donne le
téléphone tu règles le problème
retrouvera la personne dans la scène et
euh
j'appellerai gentiment la police tu vois
je dirais occupez-vous de votre mon ami
Delormeau
j'ai eu une tentative de d'escroquerie
en fait enfin donc
oui oui il y a longtemps
en province et je me suis dit plutôt que
voilà plutôt que trouver des des des des
des compagnies en province je vais
partir avec quelqu'un donc vous voyez et
en fait j'ai eu je lui ai donné
rendez-vous à la gare de Lyon et en fait
il faut que je vous mime parce que la
personne je la voyais de temps en temps
voilà c'était voilà c'était c'était pas
le problème non non je vois pas et
surtout
ta gueule et en fait et en fait je sais
pas pourquoi je j'arrive à la gare de
Lyon et de loin je vois la personne et
alors qu'on n'était pas voilà c'était
pas mal c'était pas très amoureux elle
me fait une sortie mais c'était elle
courait mon ordi elle courait au ralenti
comme pas meilleur merci
ça ça sent le ça sent la pas par hasard
et en fait elle avait convoqué les
paparazzis elle attendait qu'on saute
dans les bras et j'ai pour une fois pour
moi qui suis tout le temps noir cette
fois-ci j'ai dit ah il y a peut-être un
truc et donc j'ai fait comme ça et donc
on sait on s'est suivi à distance et
j'ai quand même eu droit à paparazade
qui est parti tous les magazines à mon
avis elle a dû partir un public c'est là
c'est facile je crois bien que oui elle
est partie et en fait et en fait j'ai
j'ai pu bloquer les photos parce que
effectivement on était de voilà on se
suivait il y avait rien de grave mais ok
la rencontre évidemment la vérité moi
aussi ça alors il m'arrive à peu près la
même histoire vous voyez non je te jure
c'est vrai et la meuf elle est tout
préparée voilà pas paradis tout ça c'est
vrai je suis à la gare la meuf arrive
elle court et voilà et comme c'était
Daniel j'ai eu le temps vraiment de
rentrer chez moi de manger de manger
[Rires]
des inconnus chez toi tu la vérité à
l'époque à l'époque oui j'étais sur
NRJ12 après j'étais quasiment tout le
temps en couple et pardon j'amène pas de
genre chez moi et les gens n'arrivent
pas chez moi je ne suis pas sur les
sites actuels dont vous parlez d'accord
si vous voyez des photos c'est pas moi
donc voilà je réponds quasiment à
personne sur Instagram j'ai plutôt une
vie de moine de moi en vrai en vrai tu
sais où je m'amuse à l'étranger d'accord
j'espère parce qu'on avait fait je me
souviens une fois on avait fait un 31
vegasme
je te dis
il fait froid là-bas et donc on avait
fait un 31 à Vegas pour le jour de l'an
et c'était la thématique c'était 31
garçons de 31 ans si génial c'était
hyper drôle 31 cm hahaha
on s'est souhaité bonne année
en brochette quoi de toute manière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te dis bonne année
ça va
j'ai d'autres gens à voir non mais sans
déconner ah ouais quand même les
souvenirs moi je suis très créatif ça
veut dire
et parfois je fais des dîners kublot ah
ouais qu'on est 8 on est que blanc je
fais des bénévis Kings il faut que tu
sois
musclée
viens avec ton ami célibataire non ah
ouais que je m'étais tapé
des thématiques
vieilles non
et c'est rigolo tu préfères une
thématique avec Daniel je te jure 31
décembre je suis libre
Daniel tu aimerais bien aller une soirée
comme ça
et si on a et si on a tenté un siècle